you're in New York you shoot New York
yeah okay and you wake up you're in your
hotel yeah you know you're about to get
on set are you nervous no saliva that's
what I want to know no saliva no
selection you woke up with no saliva
woke up let me ask you this we able to
even sleep no yeah exactly okay good I
need to I need the details yeah very
sporadic sleep right just you know
because you question yourself should I
be here am I good enough yeah yeah what
am I doing so crazy I love hearing this
yeah yeah it was it was it was I bet you
had your lines down though well that was
that was a big thing for me because the
lines and I don't know how you feel
about this at your age what does that
mean uh I just feel like the older you
get the harder it is to memorize lines
yes do you find this yes
so for me
I had to keep keep doing Lions day off
you know day off I'm in the I'm
rehearsing and rehearsing and rehearsing
because I'm like I ain't gonna be the
guy going up against especially in
dinero yeah and I'm gonna be on line and
they're gonna go what did he say oh my
God he didn't prepare for this yeah I
don't know but also can I just say this
too it's not as if you did 30 movies
before that is this how many movies had
you done before that I want to say like
three or four right but not this level
at all but the the movies they did
before this was like
little Poppins played a priest right
played a comedian you know like it was
nothing to this level level right I
can't imagine multiple days normally I
go in a day yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
six days yeah so you go so now you're
you're you're you go in and then you see
the guys you see patchy
I don't see anybody I come into the room
ironically enough the scene is taking
place
at Gotham Comedy Club in New York
amazing they took which is the first
place I did comedy in New York City wow
they they redid it to make it look like
the Copacabana
wow so I don't know at the time they
were managing you too right I don't know
zillies were they mad I think they won
yes they were yeah yeah they were so
they own the comedy club too so he
probably felt extra comfortable there I
felt comfortable there but I felt
uncomfortable because who was in the
room I mean Scorsese comes out and we're
waiting for Pesci and De Niro to come
you know so I'm the first one there
I'm not one of these guys you gotta
knock twice on the on the on the trailer
door you knock I'm out yeah
hold on yeah I'm ready yeah so I I come
to set they come
and the Nero comes up to me and goes um
are you doing are you doing good things
and I was like ah this is this is nice
whatever insane I don't know if they
told him to say it just just tell them
that but it was nice no one tells them
what to say all right hey hey Bobby make
sure you say these things there's no way
okay she was really nice hey how you
doing my name is Joe and Sebastian
Scorsese just was very happy I felt like
right away I'm like okay
because sometimes I think in your head
you make it more than what it's going to
be yeah and when I got there I felt very
comfortable however I also felt an
immense amount of pressure
because I've never done this before at
this level with this type of talent so
we we do the first scene and
um like they're cut and I'm like and
then they then this has got weird for me
cut
Scorsese comes out dinero him and Pesci
are in a huddle
where's your and I'm not in the hospital
would you oh you're the team okay if you
were doing that yeah
would you walk over to the Huddle and go
what's going on no no what I would do is
they for a huddle is a wall yeah right
but there are gaps in the wall
oh they're not gaps and walls I always
stuck my head in between a gap
oh so yeah I want to cut in there
somehow a hand you don't mean something
this is what it would be like it would
be like it'd be like this cut
and I turned to you too I said come here
guys yeah would you come over to
oh because the hand gesture yeah because
he didn't call you over no no he did oh
you don't call her you don't go over
yeah you don't go over you don't go yeah
he's gonna call you over yeah yeah he's
the captain of the football team yeah
there was no call yeah yeah okay so in
my head I'm thinking
it's over it's over oh my God why don't
you do this we all do that I do it right
yeah yeah yeah it's over they're trying
to figure out how to edit can we get
another guy in here
I love it I love it yeah how long's a
huddle
let me just tell you or yeah are they
talking about where are we gonna go to
dinner tonight
social thing yeah I don't know you don't
know because I don't know how they know
they've been doing this together for 30
40 years together yeah yeah so I feel
like they have a shorthand okay so they
break the Huddle all right we're gonna
do it again Scorsese comes up to me he's
like you know what you know it's your
try why don't you try this one you're
doing that I said okay
but in a nice way not not like you did
anything wrong right right
so there's there's a point in the scene
where I referenced Joe Pesci's lapel it
has a a pin on it from the Italian
um uh I I forget it was an Italian
organization and I and my character
don't like the pin yeah so I I flicked I
flicked the lapel what do you got this
sign for right yeah cause I'm supposed
to be a cocky [__] on this whole
thing
so I do this two or three times and
Catherine Narducci who is the actress
playing his wife who I know
says
Joe's getting a little
gray oh that you flick in the the thing
and I go is it in the script
now on a script also you improvised yeah
I was improvising you don't like
provides flicks man that's the rubber
that's the wrong advisor no why is there
number one that's the first thing you
don't [__] impress me
flicks slaps punches you don't improvise
them what the [__] is going on in your
mind my friend it was just a choice
bad choice bad choice that's your Pepsi
you could flick you know what if you and
I are doing a movie I have a pic flick
all you want it's free dude but not
[__] with pet she dude that's crazy
yeah
hindsight it was like all right it might
have been a bold move but she let's keep
doing it because
and I don't know like and again I don't
know if they were scheming with me or
what or just to get the best performance
because it because he he's going to get
angry later on in the scene and this is
this is definitely propelling wow to to
go there wow and then she starts giving
me pointers on how to behave with dinero
in the scene
is everyone pranking you yeah what is
going on I don't know what's going on
yeah so passion takes a a almost a
directorial role in in going you got to
get the narrow pissed off because he's
going to kill you in the next scene and
you need to you know so he's given me
and I'm like oh wow this is this there's
a lot going on I'm at this point I'm
going I just need to do standing and
then the Wardrobe comes up and gives you
acting now I think you should do this
with your shoe you're like
it's enough yeah yeah yeah so actors are
giving you notes yeah yeah but it's not
just any actors you know it's still
Patrick she's telling you to do
something right you know you do it and
was it conflicting was that note
conflicting with Scorsese no no at this
at this point scorsese's not even coming
out of it there's like a black drape or
scorses he is and he's not a video
Village yeah he's not even coming out
he's kind of letting this all happen and
again I don't know
what what's being said or if he's
telling Joe to do this or what have you
long story short it was like a an
intense six day acting lesson for me wow
being around these guys wow and I didn't
leave I didn't leave the set going
Bob call me next week we'll do dinner it
wasn't like that relationship yeah yeah
he then De Niro came I think six months
later to see me do a show in New York
City he came back yeah I remember the
photo yeah yeah
and even then we didn't really talk